what is the fact that Hitler took power
teaching about human nature when you
look back at the history of the 20th
century what what do you learn from that
time
I mean there are a bunch of lessons to
Hitler taking power the the first thing
I think people
ought to recognize about Hitler taking
power is that the power had been
centralized in the government before
Hitler took it so if you actually look
at the history of Nazi Germany the
Weimar Republican effectively collapsed
the power had been centralized in the
chancellory uh and and really under
Hindenburg for a couple of years before
that and so it was only a matter of time
until someone who was bad grabbed the
power and so the struggle between the
Reds and the Browns in Nazism in in
pre-nazi Germany led to this kind of up
spiraling of radical sentiment that
allowed Hitler in through the front door
not through the back door right he was
elected so you think Communists could
have also taken power I mean there's no
question coming it's going to take him
power there were serious force in
prenats in Germany do you think there
was an underlying current that would
have led to an atrocity if the
Communists have taken power wouldn't
have been quite the same atrocity but
obviously the Communists in Soviet
Russia at exactly this time where we're
committing the haladimir yeah right so
they so it was there were there were
very few good guys in terms of good
parties the moderate parties were being
dragged by the radicals into alliance
with them to prevent the worst case
scenario from the other guy right so if
you look at I'm sort of fascinated by
the the history of this period because
it really does speak to how does a
democracy break down I mean the 20s
Republic was a very liberal democracy
how does a liberal democracy break down
into complete Fascism and then into
genocide and there's a character who you
know was very prominent in the history
of that time and in Franz von papen who
was actually the second to last
Chancellor of the Republic before Hitler
so he was the chancellor and then he
handed over to Schleicher and then he
ended up Schleicher ended up collapsing
and that ended up handing power over to
Hitler it was papenhood stumped for
Hitler to become Chancellor uh papin was
a was a Catholic Democrat he didn't like
Hitler he thought that Hitler was a
radical and a nut job but he also
thought that Hitler being a buffoon as
he saw it was going to essentially be
usable by the right forces in order to
get the in order to prevent the
Communists from taking power
maybe in order to restore some sort of
legitimacy to the regime because he was
popular
in order for papin to retain power
himself
and then immediately after Hitler taking
power Hitler basically kills all of
papin's friends papin out of quote
unquote loyalty stays on he ends up
helping the Angeles and Austra you know
all this stuff is really interesting
mainly because what it speaks to is the
great light we tell ourselves that
people who are evil are not like us
they're they're classified people who do
evil things people who support evil
people people they're not like us and
that that that's an easy call everybody
everybody in history who has sinned is a
person who's very different from me
Robert George the philosopher over at
Princeton he's fond of doing a sort of
thought experiment in his classes where
he asks people to raise their hand if
they had lived in Alabama in 1861 how
many of you would be abolitionists and
everybody raises their hand he says of
course that's not true
of course that's not true right the the
best protection against evil is
recognizing that it lies in every human
heart and the possibility that it takes
you over and so you have to be very
cautious in how you approach
these issues and the back and forth of
Politics the sort of bipolarity of
Politics the the or the uh polarization
in politics might be a better way to put
it you know makes it very easy to to
kind of fall into the Rock'em sock'em
robots that eventually could
theoretically allow you to support
somebody who's truly
frightening and hideous in order to stop
somebody who you think is more
frightening and hideous and he's this
kind of language by the way now
predominating almost all over the
Western World right my political enemy
is an enemy of democracy my political
enemy is going to end the Republic my
political enemy is going to be the
person who destroys the country we live
in and so
that person
has to be stopped by any means necessary
and that's that's dangerous stuff so the
Communists had to be stopped in Nazi
Germany and so they're the devil and so
any useful buffoon
as long as they're effective against the
Communists would do do you ever wonder
because the people that are
participating in evil may not understand
that they're doing evil
do you ever sit back
you know in the quiet of your mind and
think am I participating in evil I mean
that so my business partner and I uh one
of our our favorite memes is uh from
there's a British comedy show The Name
Escapes Me of these two guys who are
members of the SS and they're dressed in
the SS uniforms and the black uniforms
the skulls on them and they're saying to
each other one says to the other guy you
notice like the the British the the
symbol is something is something nice
and it's like it's like an eagle but uh
it's a skull and crossbones you see that
the Americans you see that they're blue
uniforms they're very nice and pretty
awesome jet black are we the baddies and
you know that's it and the truth is we
look back at at the Nazis and we say
well of course they were the baddies
they wore black uniforms they had Jack
Boots and they had this and and of
course they were the bad guys but evil
rarely presents its face so clearly so
yeah I mean I think you have to
constantly be thinking along those lines
and hopefully you try to avoid it
yeah you can only do the best that a
human being can do but yeah I mean the
answer is yes if it I would say that
I spend
an inordinate amount of time reflecting
on whether I'm doing the right thing and
I may not always do the right thing I'm
sure a lot of people think that I'm
doing the wrong thing on a daily basis
but um it's definitely a question that
has to enter your mind as a as a
historically
aware and hopefully more ladies in
person do you think you're mentally
strong enough if you realize
that you're on on the wrong side of
History to switch sides very few people
in history seem to be strong enough to
do that I mean I think that the answer I
hope would be yes you never know until
the time comes and you have to do it I
will say that having heterodox opinions
in a wide variety of areas is uh is
something that that I have done before
I'm the only
person I've ever heard of in in public
life who actually has a list on their
website of all the dumb stupid things
I've ever said uh so where I go through
and I either say this is why I still
believe this or this is why what I said
was terrible and stupid yeah um and I'm
sure that list will get a lot longer
yeah look forward continue addition to
that yeah exactly yeah it actually is a
super super long list people should
check it out and it's quite honest and
raw